austrians have been rushing to get
covered 19 vaccinations before strict
new rules come into force there health
authorities in austria have registered
registered a record number of nearly 10
000 new infections in a single day
all over austria people are thronging to
get jabbed
long lines in front of covet 19
vaccination centers even buses converted
into makeshift inoculation facilities
yesterday around 5 000 people were
vaccinated here
in the last week or two it's only been a
thousand or 1200 a day so this is a lot
more
from monday anyone not at least
partially vaccinated or recovered from a
coronavirus infection is barred from
entering cafes restaurants
or hair salons
in a month's time they'll need to be
fully vaccinated
the scans are deemed as this is a strong
incentive for people to go and get
vaccinated
that is our big goal
we need to boost the vaccination rate
so we're having to tighten the rules for
the unvaccinated
but i want to make one thing very clear
no one wants to divide no one wants a
division in the population
around 64 of austria's population is
fully vaccinated
that is below the average in western
europe and not enough to prevent a
certain coronavirus cases
intensive care units are filling up fast
increased immunity is seen as the only
way to avoid another deadly wave in the
pandemic